okay four people joining us live stream
this is part 2 of this month's
suggestions and priorities discussion
about wolf language we had a very good
if long discussion on Friday where we
went through a bunch of topic areas and
we are going to keep going with other
topic areas this is being seeded by the
red mind system that we have been using
to track pre-release comments about our
upcoming version 12.1 but other comments
can come in on the livestream however we
have only a particular set of people
relevant for the topics that were in the
red mine list who are here so people
bring in completely other things we may
or may not be able to address them if we
can't address them this time we will
address them another time and hopefully
we have notes from the previous time of
things that we were unable to address
hopefully those can be found okay we're
gonna start off with graphs and networks
so morphological graph return pixel
coordinates
the edges this is not
this is an image processing issue isn't
it yes
just so you can see their sorcery
reported two days ago it's nothing
processed yet by you know the people
that process these things so that's
maybe why it's miss assigned in
misreported I see
okay so coordinates register i can't
address this one unless shadi is here i
don't think we can address this one
today um oops what just happened here i
went back and it just oh gosh that's bad
how do i how do I go I see I have to
this is Carlton you okay
I don't find longest path function I
think we we already discussed that
didn't we lost time Charles yes yes I
think um that's a display form for
shortest path function we discussed that
one too and we said yes okay Graaff
generators to produce natural vertex
names we talked about that as well
I believe no okay let's take a look at
that one great graphs use the index of
vertices as vertex names grid graph
the grid indices well that's an
interesting idea
well we have it is depend of when it's
useful we do it like you know nope
there's a bunch of cough when we do it
and in some case you have to take into
account a bunch of things like the
amount of memory used specially like it
could cough where you get you know a
huge amount of you know where it's an
air John you need to packed away such so
ok so if I say grid graph of like five
five I will get that grid graph and
you're telling me that if I were to say
vertex names arrow or vertex labels are
automatic in this graph is okay but so
how would I get the coordinate positions
not position here he won't do three
pearls you know here is it doubles
doubles one one that's why I mean the
coordinate positions on the grid right
the coordinate position on the grid so
it's not unique you just need to mark
them there's no guarantee that it has to
be one one no no I understand that but I
mean just like these numbers are not
unique we could put these numbers at
anything we want okay wait what I'm
saying is what he's saying what I'm
saying is there is given the way this
was generated there is a natural
coordinate system I mean it could be
anywhere it could start off at zero zero
in the middle it could do a bunch of
different things but there is the the
question is if the generator of the
graph knows something about the natural
names of the nodes it would be nice to
pass that through potentially yes and we
do that for some class we decided not to
do that for you know one of the latest
one is near race mesh connectivity we do
that near as graph we do that
automatically is also part of the whole
manipulation so we had to make a
decision between generating them base
you know how much memory will cost a bit
but Charles that's not the default we
understand it
the default the question is I mean so in
this case and and j-bolts I think on the
live stream is asking at least document
what the order is for grid graph so this
is effectively a pairing function or a
tuple in function that you're using to
find a way to make a linear description
of all of these right I mean you
couldn't general use you know one of
these can't or pairing function thingies
or some generalization of that to go
through the grid and make a
one-dimensional sequence out of it right
all right so you're you are picking a
particular ordering which seems to be
and it might be good to at least
document what that mapping is for grid
glove make sense okay I'm not convert I
don't see yeah it's case when is really
useful and we have function to you know
if you want to do the mapping if you
want to replace the vertex you want to
use tuples you do you know you can use
antes graph you can use they taste good
place yeah I understand that understand
that but we know when we generate this
graph we know the mapping from
coordinate positions into graph
positions right when you say coordinate
you mean something else than vertex
coordinates just so we're clear
yeah yeah I mean I mean the conceptual
coordinates that made this grid okay I
mean it just seems like an easy thing to
document given that we are doing in a
definite way but the question of whether
there should be other places where I'm
not to converse on the community because
he's also implemented on base right so
that may be look how I said to that
implementation well fine but then maybe
maybe it's not that maybe we didn't even
think it through properly what the
sequence is
in any case I don't know I mean it seems
like make new work of questionable value
you can see the self or complete cough
where you want them from left to right
but you can't see the symbol for star
graph where you want the center to be
one and then the point with certain
position you can pretty much require
that aadmi for all cough constructors
okay so for example in this case here
yeah okay I mean that does some
perfectly reasonable ordering there the
order we generate for sure is in more
natural default order that part on this
instance show well okay so showboats is
making the point that one needs to be
able to depend on the ordering if one's
gonna use these functions
why why why we have they Texas for that
we you know why you mean you go from
vertex list but you don't know where it
is in the okay so thread I see so that's
in fact what it's doing here
yes we have to top those you can map it
seats yeah I know so long as it doesn't
change what it's doing all right let's
move on from this topic I mean this is
clearly a more complicated topic um edge
that's a different issue
alright this is
more on this another time this is I
think a bit complicated here I mean my
feeling my only my summary about this is
there should be a way to get access to
whatever the underlying generator
expression was for that vertex why I
mean so one thing is we'll be trying to
maintain a certain abstraction here
because it gives flexibility to use
alternate implementations so if you rely
on some property like that then it's I
mean that's that's like a side effect
that's not what the property of the
graph is at that point so let's move its
I'm not saying that someone can't come
up with it with an important reason why
but I don't I haven't heard it yet
yeah I think the point is yeah the point
being made here is if you need to rely
on the positions I know I have to say I
suspect I may even have code now that
relies on positions in oh maybe not
maybe not because yeah it will be good
at least in the documentation for grid
graph to show how you can get given that
you're not going to rely on this how you
can find the coordinate position so to
speak of a vertex in the graph should
you need to do so no it's how you can
discover that mapping which you surely
can do just by graph distances right it
doesn't it always also change when you
change the embedding often no absolutely
not it has nothing to do with the
embedding no no that point given that
this is the origin whatever we're
calling the origin that point is that
graph distance it's a well Manhattan
distance us in such such and such for
for or something right to 2 to node 4
hmm I don't know exactly how to get this
well I mean I would put something to
[ __ ] Billy show how you can always get
that that shouldn't be a problem in the
documentation alright let's start with
that okay place my divisor we got a
bunch of background noise if we can cut
that I'll be good um the some point from
even here about placement of edge labels
on an edge tag graph is problematic I
don't know about that can you comment on
that Charles I mean the edge tag graphs
are a new thing
um white so the urge to graph
essentially you target edge so forceful
I'd find offsets find shortest path we
turn diverted the vertices you actually
Traverse right so obviously the person
here wants to edge but I see and well
like similar to the other case we you
know we need a choice here to return
more list of vertices specially because
we want to keep the talkshow condense a
factory of integer when you have example
sure the case where you have multiple
edges right you can always say which am
i picking when a to the traversal matter
if there's no if it's a multi graph it
doesn't matter which I do pick when the
coffee's weighted okay so where you pick
the smallest vertex so smallest edge so
that's the only case so as I said
earlier you know there is a lot of
motion a to remain adds review and prove
because you have now tagged edge so yes
it sounds like it sounds like we could
imagine a shortest path a a second
argument or something except shortest
path already has second argument but
some argument to shortest path that says
what you want to return right sure an
early on to not create a new object like
a path object
because then we need a whole arithmetic
and set the manipulation on that object
yeah I understand where is a vertex list
presumably you can just depend vertex
lists and you will get a longer path for
instance yeah right oh this is something
to look at this is a more complicated
thing we're not gonna solve it instantly
um but let's see a graph
oh I see the list of edges
yeah this is exactly what you were
talking about weighted edges yeah it's a
good point
not solved but a good point all right
how do I get I go on here
you
I have an example here on the live
stream about why
um
so gonna be a way to make a weighted
edge by itself without edge weights what
does that mean isn't a weighted edge
characterized by the edge weights isn't
that what the point of a weighted edges
yes certain but how do you make that the
question is is there a naked wicked
weighted edge independent of its
position in the graph with edge weights
I mean edge weights is an option right
yes I think because they saw a tag the
tag being a naked way to do it they want
I think that I'm guessing implicitly
there is a question can you do a similar
sort of stick the weight right in there
in the edge yes which would be a good
thing to be able to do well no is depend
if you're constructing took off you can
still use the property one rotation has
a wrapper so you can say annotation so
the idea then is that in this graph if
so if I have a graph of the form so if I
say annotation one goes to two edge
weight goes to seven or something and
2 goes to 3 3 goes to 1 or whatever
right
yeah there will work now is there any
indication there that there is a weight
on that edge that would be a nice thing
to have visually not by default no I
think mr. Critchlow but most edge label
goes to edge weight or something I don't
know exactly the stuff should keep
something like that at labeling or edge
labels edge labels and I think we had it
as a quote edge weight or something yeah
that seems that they are yeah there are
the edge weights are as beautiful as
they could be but there's something I'm
sure I can put placed sand and can I say
call out of edge weight or something
here I'll be nice could I say something
else here it can say place but we need
to give it position under coordinate now
is no the position is more based on the
the edge so you know top and middle so
we start I think is his twin start not
remember all that again yeah is this
twin start needle and well doesn't work
okay well anyway we do have the ability
to put edge weights as an annotation on
an edge which is nice and that's a nice
general way to do it um
okay Schultz's is mentioning some
detailed things which I encourage you
guys to look at after this um is that
how you say his name I don't know he can
correct me if I'm wrong but I believe
that that's correct from a previous life
stream okay sorry this doesn't come easy
I'm sure I don't have all the correct
phonemes because I didn't go up in a
maximal phoneme environment um I'm quite
certain even knew Roger could generate
Swedish phonemes that I could not
imitate yes the okay there's an auto
completion for vertex shape function um
you
it's that well that that just seems like
a bug I don't know that I need to even
type this I'm sure it's an autocomplete
bug
oh well can it support name what would
that be actually does it support that I
mean I'm just wondering what it yes it
does so that should be in the
autocomplete well we made a choice to
pick a set and set for autocomplete but
this is a useful thing to have any what
have complete I don't know what what is
this documented yes right I think this
should be in the autocomplete I see no
reason it shouldn't be able to complete
particularly if it's documented for
vertex shape function oh no but it's
missing its misunderstanding name means
these named capsule and so on no it does
no it does not
he's the named is the vertex list from
the vertex list you remember we have do
this is a different thing this is a
named vertex function but this is
something where you're using the name of
the this is confusing this is confusing
because this vertex shape function is
this is and by the way why does vertex
shape function not autocomplete with
automatic I guess because it doesn't
need to because that wouldn't you
wouldn't do that name is documented in
vertex a function well to completion we
have to pick we have a whole list of a
stick-shift function
yeah we do okay I understand that I'm
asking the question name appears to be a
possible setting for vertex shape
function it is not documented here yes
okay should it be documented here well
that's another issue you see to graph
element data
square capsule shape on such an odd
document that is the choice you need I'm
asking this thing name this name here
name like this that gives these should
that be documented I would think the
answer is yes okay my second point is
this way of doing discovery of things
like this is really not sensible and I
I thought we had agreed we're going to
talk about a general way to solve this
problem so you know whether it's musical
instruments and sound note whether it's
you know color data things they all have
slightly different mechanisms we need a
unified mechanism for discovering these
settings right so that's a separate
meeting which I think we were planning
to have yes and this should be coming
who's who's beaming here okay then okay
so can you please add that to the list
of things that will be discussed in the
meeting about I guess it will be called
settings discovery okay okay got it yeah
okay all right so this particular thing
appears to be undocumented the fact you
can use quotes name with a capital n I
don't know what else you can use here
why would you want to use name with a
capital n because isn't that just the
vertex label yeah exactly so I'm
confused here
you
confused maybe you guys cannot confuse
me we got to move on because we got lots
of stuff to go through here okay I mean
it doesn't mean it's impossible to have
but it's sort of confusing to concepts
but it's using and we just should link
to that under vertex shape function I
assume that the first link here because
and buttocks labels but that's a
reasonable thing to do all right let's
keep going here diagrams graphs tiles
should not change the vertex label
location I don't know what this is what
is graph style it's a precursor to plot
theme so this is what's now called plot
theme son we duplicated that symbol
right but nevertheless you know a plot
theme can certainly reset the the label
location you can ever yeah it's an
option so you can certainly reset that
we're rich you know so I assume that if
I were to say here um something like if
I say label style arrow you means a text
label
you
oops very confused okay let's do it
again
vertex label style was that a correct
autocomplete that I could get that
vertex yes I guess that's right okay
fine
okay so that then overrides the plot
theme a try styling that seems correct
to me okay I have not read this so is
there commentary here or is this just am
I being given the raw raw input here is
there commentary here for these or is
this just raw input because we should
have one round of commentary before we
do these I think wait a second could our
node answer that question commentary
from who or what from somebody before
it's just throwing it at me okay well
that's not the idea here let's get
commentary from whoever the appropriate
developer is before we are I hope so
QA reports internal bug reports which
are linked from this report I'm not sure
if you want to click on this particular
one but you know like what commentary is
in the internal bug report but for these
discussions we need a summary of that so
we're not just making it up okay and I'm
gonna move on unless Charles you had one
of the comments here yes so essentially
he want when you say vertex label goes
automatic we implicitly assume that you
mean the placement have to be top right
so that's why then we change the
placement so that's his only complaint
is that automatic should be disregarded
because it's automatic for what for the
vertex label placement so y-you see the
text label goes to automatic and
basically we assume that the label is
the name and the position is top right
yes so so his claim is that when you put
automatic
didn't change that if the plot style is
specified
itic kind of what shouldn't change the
position of the label but the plot theme
can do whatever it wants exactly agree
and if you don't want what it does then
override it
exactly so that's house design all right
fine
that seems sensible option for fine
graph partition to find connected
partitions does each other quests okay
I've found sensible but I don't know in
detail if there any come any further
comments on it there's no not yet in the
internal wire report okay doc you might
find communities methods okay I don't
know I mean Charles let's for you I
don't really know happy there's
something you have some comment on this
in why is depend on the level of the
documentation I believe in the
documentation of fine community we have
enough detail about it right no
modularity centrality typically Jean so
you know depending on people some people
want us to write a whole technical
document about the method that's a
choice but I don't think it's a top
priority oh no I wouldn't but I think we
should answer the question maybe
somebody could just answer on the
community just answer a few sentences of
answer for what these are and then if
people want to know that in the future
they can go look at that community post
that seems like the right way to handle
this rather than writing official
documentation for it seem reasonable yes
hydro six format for graphs
that's a import format yes
I don't know what that's really about so
that's it that will be a moss kind of a
combined format for for sparse six and
four graphs X and that is there a
standard name for that if there is we
should support it if there isn't we
shouldn't
apparently d6 is supposed to be the
standard name for that combination in
which case we should support it and that
seems like a rather easy thing to do and
let's move on do it do you agree you
disagree
I assume you've registered you read
these before this meeting yes okay fine
so what what's the answer here it's just
a suggestion we are going to look into
them okay
let's be specific on this particular one
is this do you agree do so first of all
here's how we decided which graph
formats to support originally we tracked
down 75 different libraries that use and
operate on graphs what formats do they
in fact support we picked from them the
top ten that are supported among all the
tools it wasn't willy-nilly done it
wasn't something random just saying
because it's there we gonna do it yeah
well but this one seems like it's a it's
so we need to look into it now fine fine
and it's probably evolved over the years
okay great
let's move on graph Union should support
a single argument it's a suggestion we
are going to add it's just for
uniformity okay all right fine okay do
we can we talk about how much plus the
sooner we not have the right people here
we do not have shaadi but we do have aa
so the answer is digraph six did not
exist when golf six and spa six support
was added so it's relevant to look into
again okay what I'm sorry what are you
talking about we we don't believe we
have any items still left to go with the
cloud stuff we went over that last time
did we not if not please tell me which
items are still to go so we have a
chance I would you skipped him
she's learning and neural nets working
since the most okay
all right ie okay and I must say
list is a felony to me but I'm happy to
discuss them okay that's not the right
procedure here yeah I know for a future
that's not the right procedure yeah so
my audio is I just have a lot of
background noise so I apologize for the
background noise these should all have
bug reports so I think HN should have
had at least an opportunity let me check
except a very the very newest ones not
but everything except the first one yeah
unknown layout the number of reports
from aster see was a Wolfram language
user in China who uses machine learning
quite a bit so okay that's an
interesting idea to him missing layer
which one could then do operations on
actually yes we are going to do that I'm
going to do that I'm not sure what the
timeline is but we also only that alerts
for the owner on XM port because it's a
bit annoying when you have 99% of your
networking in porn and just one that
doesn't important then doesn't work just
because of that right so then you were
hand then you can hand edit the missing
layer yeah okay great
okay new layer requests pixel
normalization layer I do not know what
that is but I can sort of guess from the
name
I don't know about this attend can you
comment on this I don't know either
something to look into we don't but if
it's exactly if it's used you know in a
known Network classic networks and
probably shredded okay pixel shuffle
layer no idea these are obviously ones
feeder look into I simply don't know
about them yeah more resolving methods
for resize layer
so that's a good question why resize
layer doesn't use the same kind of
sampling methods that image resize users
for example by just calling those
functions I mean for one it has to be
done on you know possibly on GPU and so
on
so we cannot just add any function right
but okay so then the thought here will
be talked to the image processing team
and find out what kinds of resizing we
have already defined for image resize
yeah probably they can be implemented in
an X net in some way
well that's interesting this doesn't
list methods here which is odd
surprised by that maybe there aren't
different methods Oh resampling method I
see
I see there's a whole zoo of methods
here so the question is how that relates
to what's being discussed here and even
whether the resampling option has I mean
possibly the useful resampling option
and resize layer etc
make sense yep
validation set eros scale should work
for classify and predict that's a good
idea to have validation set being scaled
of something gives a says use this
fraction of the set as validation right
yeah that's true
it works for on a train and and I guess
it was an innovation of that train that
we didn't backcourt to classify and
predict we should okay migrate that was
easy
okay
simple lower level API that sounds much
more complicated
you
yes definitely that's something that we
are going to go eventually but we want
to try to put as much of typical user of
neural network in high-level API first I
believe that often when people wants a
low-level API then before that there's
still things we can improve in the
high-level one and and right but I mean
the fact is that as a timing issue if we
offered better access to the low-level
API that still might be you know six
months ahead of where we will actually
get high-level support for some
particular feature now of course you
know MX net and so on also moving target
you know and we've been contributing
lots to that and making it a moving
target so I don't know exactly what the
interface looks like there I mean I have
to say that our in general our
experience with providing low-level
interfaces has been mixed I mean we have
you know we could review what they are I
mean things like you know embedded HTML
in in the cloud that I think is fairly
successful although it has issues about
you know what you can communicate I mean
you know what tends to happen with these
all of interfaces then people say oh but
I want access to this high level feature
from within the low-level interface and
then sorry you can't do that I mean we
used to have back a long long time ago
when our graphics was firmly based on
PostScript we used to let people go and
okay so this is one of these stories
right I mean we used to let people go
and have raw access to the PostScript
primitives underneath the graphics well
if I look back at the code that I have
for the nks book that makes graphics
basically a hundred percent of that code
works today except the little places
where it has a hack that went directly
into the PostScript and that doesn't
work anymore so you know it's a kind of
a trade-off but I think in terms of
timing and as an experimental thing
having the ability to you know access
these low-level things easily and if
there are as this person is claiming a
modest number of interface points that
seems like it would be
worthwhile tech report to describe those
although you know it's a trade-off
between if that's a small amount of time
to do that um you know that's fine if
it's a large amount of time we might as
well be actually building the high level
interface
think it'd be worth just looking at the
stuff and maybe maybe the person who
wrote this who's figured out could write
a community post about it and that would
be a good start eternally for the
Commerce zone no I agree we should look
at that maybe this particular demand are
sensible I guess another comment that
that's too type of going low level one
is allowing the user to write custom
layers and that's something we
definitely want to do hopefully using
the compile function the new compiler
that should allow to do that that's and
the second thing is allowing to have
access to the training loop which is a
bit different and that thing we're going
to wait a little bit more to to output
that but but I will look at this Y with
respect to the training loop so we would
need a well it's it's suddenly it's it's
much more complex it's like you're
getting the gradient yourself you're
doing the optimization yourself but why
don't we just give a boatload I mean why
don't we just say okay you want the
training loop yourself here's this
association with a boatload of stuff in
it
that yes we could do some actually
actually that's probably what we're
going to do maybe not an association but
just a sort of reasonable object that
that and then you could still use net
shrine maybe just for one step and but
you have the result of a new network of
code but also the state of the optimizer
and everything else you need to continue
training and anything access of course
all the information in this regime
object so that could be one way to so
sorry it's kind of a net training object
that then can be recomputed with or you
can subscribe properties of exactly
exactly
so I think that would be that would be
the way they were the way to go right I
mean I I don't know what happens in
terms of loading and unloading from GPUs
and things that might be complicated
because I assume that when you're inside
net train things are resident in the GPU
and everything so yes yes I think with
the resumable it would still like we
wouldn't empties memory really but does
it does it no I mean so if you had a net
training object
maybe that has pointers into the raw GPU
memory that I I never understand how
GPUs interact with operating systems I
have to say it's always struck me as
mysterious um of when does it know you
know if you have a pointer into the raw
GPU memory and then you have some other
CPU code that's running before it goes
back into the GPU stuff how does that
work
did you understand my question I mean so
if the thing is if there's a program
running in the GPU and just does what it
does I understand that but if it if it
stopped running in the GPU and
potentially the operating system swapped
something else in there and then it does
some CPU stuff and then it goes back to
the GPU how do you know whether the
stuff is still where and what manages
that yeah I don't exactly know what
manages I know that that we do it
because the pre-processing is done with
the CPU and and the actual network
learning is done on the GPU and for now
actually we're not supporting more
because the I think it waits for the CPU
to be over and then GPU continues but of
course we don't empty the memory it's
still there in the GPU this would take a
long time to each time load in the GPU
and do the computation and undo that
again right but I don't mean the fact is
Ethan our live stream is commenting them
you know modern networks allow dynamic
top-level code yeah well eventually
you're just doing an arbitrary
computation here and you know in in a
sense we made a decision early on and I
neural network development that you know
we had an earlier design that was
basically you know building that future
that is now emerging from the beginning
so to speak of just allowing arbitrary
functions we didn't do that because that
was was it was by seven years ago now
and that was way before any of these
capabilities would be efficient and you
know now what we have to do is figure
out how we sort of go from you know how
we start putting arbitrary top level
code into something which will turn into
essentially a neural net loop in terms
of net function yeah the the main hold
up a net function has been how much
should the compiler compile before it's
worth you know using it for to create
net function I think it's pretty much at
the point probably in the next round of
compiler work we will be trying to
insert things with that function maybe a
10 can say more about
I would like to have it in the I mean at
what point one but 12.2 at least as
experimental and I don't see a
fundamental problem with this I mean I
think that the the code generation from
the compiler should allow us to do this
the only thing that's going to go wrong
is some that people are going to say oh
I really would like to use this function
in my net function and it's not
supported but you know I think the the
argument somehow I you know it's a
design question okay
the general principle of design right of
of you don't give users an expectation
that something is going to work and then
block it as in you know if we say if if
the kinds of functions people expect to
work namely arithmetic function things
like this if those all work then I
suppose that's that's something if they
then expect that you know a
combinatorial optimization is going to
work inside the net function loop well
it's not going to work there at least
not not in the short term um but you
know I think I think it's probably
something where we can reasonably get
net function working through whatever
the compiler can currently compile yeah
of course there would be many Stepney's
project at first the user will have to
write the gradient as well and then
maybe its own future we can do the
automatic differentiation so user don't
have to write a gradient it's kind of
bizarre man we had some version of
automatic differentiation for like
decades and we still don't have that as
a as a feature that we can use for
example in a and I mean we're going to
need it for this net function capability
right we're gonna need to be able to
derive I mean okay question from the
compiler I thought Rob had been working
maybe Roger knows about because I
thought Robert been working on automatic
differentiation in the context of the
compiler is that a true statement
but it's not it's it's not finished I
understand it in the GNU Compiler
talking about the previous stuff was the
old compiler and it that also is not
finished you know it was a partial
automatic differentiation and the new
yeah well the new one I well you tell me
I don't it's not clear to me what the
state of the compiler team is these days
it's chugging forward and building all
kinds of interesting things it's some it
is it should be ready to I mean there's
no reason why we couldn't work on
automatic differentiation with what the
compiler has right now the compiler is a
big project and has many there many
shorter term deliverables that are
arriving like the data structures
capability of version 12.1 right but not
the compiler itself is not I mean yes
the compiler itself has many many new
things in 12.1 but the compiler isn't
finished because it never will be right
it's an infinite project but I think
that the parts of the compiler necessary
to do automatic differentiation of
functions which can be realistically
automatically differentiated should be
ready by now and I think it's a
reasonable thing to do and it's
something Etienne will need to pull
together for the snap function
functionality and I mean that's another
criterion of you know that's another
part of what expectation be setting what
kinds of functions can appear inside a
net function because they need to be
automatically differentiable right
because many functions are not okay
let's keep going
yeah matrix functions and vector
functions became it's it's another thing
which we don't have symbolic
differentiation of symbolic matrix
expressions in top-level
yes but you would very much like that in
a setting like this right but that's a
whole world of symbolic matrix
operations
yes which which you know which we've
supported in sit for four years in some
cases for symbolic tensors but we've
never done the more specific case of
symbolic matrices yeah
that's not enough the tensor stuff I
mean you want determinant and you want
so I understand that you want things
that are specific to matrices that don't
work for general tensors right yeah so I
mean the the I mean that is an
interesting framework that for whatever
reason we've not found important over
the years but it's an interesting thing
to be thinking about I don't think
that's on the short term roadmap unless
we need some version of it for net
function and so on okay
mention any lost this looks like a very
detailed point yeah this this is the
yeah it's a burg and genomics it okay
and yeah we're pretty happy that someone
found it good thank you for finding it
okay
had total examples total batchest
training progress panel I I don't know
that seems like a detailed thing Bertie
and I think that's been tagged as low
priority but yeah we've got it
okay adversarial networks known that
support isn't that coming yes exactly
that's what they never get about right
all right that should be in 12.1
you
so hopefully we have that if there's
anything ok custom neuron that layers
that's net function that should be
merged with the other discussion here oh
no no it wasn't actually specifically on
here alright that's that
okay that was neuron that's now do we
have okay that was all all the items for
that um ok should we go on
good alright notebook previews for
Dropbox and Friends okay this looks like
it's a John full story by the way at end
I think that that is everything for you
if I'm not mistaken can somebody else
comment on that please
all right I'm gonna go then
thanks a lot bye-bye bye okay
[Music]
John are you with us
I am I might have a slight bit of
background noise because I was trying to
make myself some lunch
but yeah fair enough but late for lunch
depending where you are but um okay not
book previews for Dropbox and friends so
no reviews are something that we've
looked at in a variety of contexts
yeah well Google Drive don't we don't we
have that swimmin this is this is for
the cloud isn't it well I mean it's in
the context of their clouds
yeah I understand so we've been so bunch
of these folks we've been working with
ya and i'm you know i i've not been in
the loop on this state of what exactly
is going on with google drive and how
how our integration is looking there I
mean I know there's been work though
it's either released or about to be
released to somebody is yon here still
or did yon disappear because we told him
I'm still here actually um I don't know
whether we officially release it yet but
uh you know I'm very shortly do is there
a page we can show for it I don't think
so
no but the idea would be that within
Google Drive you installable from app
and then you can just open a notebook
file yeah yeah so that's a separate
issue and that's I mean I know for some
of these organizations some of these
companies I know that our partnerships
group has been working with them but
that seems like it is more an item for
the partnerships group than for us since
we're not in control of what the
previewer is so the first statement yeah
yeah fine let's move on so that that
needs to get get ask you that just is
there even anything to do on a desktop
isn't that the whole point of these
things they behave like another drive
well this is primarily when you're
dealing with their websites
you know you
to Dropbox's website you go and you know
they'll show you like they'll render PDF
for you or - or github you know which
can render various things this for
example no well when you know some of
these places we are actively working
with so hopefully there will be good
solutions there but let's say I think
there's a partnerships problem not a not
a problem to be solved from our
technology stack um unless there was a
standard I mean something like Oh in bed
which is we had to do something special
when Apple decided to show previous
right and we did something special for
yes for the Mac OS but that was working
with Apple that wasn't a we just do
something that's right right
so that's why I'm saying this is a thing
which is a a it's a partnership issue
and to identify which of the relevant
things and I don't know the precise
state of all of them um but that's so
you know from this meeting that needs to
be passed to partnerships crew and they
may already have solutions for all of
these I do not know but it's not know
about it thank you okay ugly font and
docked cells
Tom I've seen this report as a bug on
that yeah
I'm not clear what's going on yet what
what is the what is the issue I'm not
sure okay we have no idea it's not
something that's reproducible everywhere
thank you I need the lift log linear
plug Thanks what okay I'm gonna assume
that's just a bug I'm not gonna look at
it here slide transitions missing and
presented tools yeah I I don't know what
the current state of that is that will
be Andres team who would know about that
I believe anybody here know about that I
thought that slide that I thought there
was a bunch of very elaborate work on
slide transitions it seemed to me over
elaborate actually um I mean I hate
these slide shows where there's where
things do kind of elaborate you know
movie directors style well but now's
when we be talking about them with the
new Star Wars movie out and deal right
yeah when you get all your whites and
your whatever yeah um I think the dye
toward it now there's a little fake
that's the problem like not totally
trailer being after well I don't know
what transitions exist in and I mean I I
never use them but I don't know what
transition well the transitions that
exist the front end directly provides
there there oh I don't remember the list
but it I mean it's not it's not anywhere
near like for example what you're gonna
find in PowerPoint I think there may be
half a dozen but so the question is are
people using them if they are and they
want more than that's what we'd like to
know and then what are the top ones that
people would like that we don't
currently have okay better formatting of
notebook items in the window menu
that's a good background that's a good
point actually that's a good point it's
a good point it's a very well down here
it's a very you know bland list it's not
interesting here but sometimes I have a
list that goes all the way down to here
and it is true that there is no
organization in those and it would be
nice if there was some iconography is
that something that is readily edible or
is that something where that's the
operating system that controls that menu
well so we I mean all the menu work that
we've done so far has been standard
stuff and you know we can you know
clearly there are applications out there
that you know that do kind of custom
drawn menus and we can do it too
the big problem is there's a certain
issue of you know economy of effort in
terms of you know if we do that it has
to be implemented three times you know
once for my windows and the weapons for
Windows once for Cutie so right and you
know it just as a general matter of
priorities for things that have to be
implemented three times you know the
priorities need to be a bit higher a bit
but this being able to group
documentation notebooks at the bottom of
the window that's a reasonable thing to
do I think that's a break those off and
let that just separate them off with a
separator that seems like a very readily
doable thing um yeah I mean I think one
of the issues here is that we are not
indicating the things like the folder
that the notebook is in and we could
probably do that in other words putting
a parenthetical after the name of the
after the name here seems like it would
be a fairly straightforward thing to do
like for example I will often have a
bunch of things which have the same name
in different folders I mean I think
these will be you know let's let's look
at some basic things like that but at
least separating off the documentation
ones does seem like a good suggestion
make sense yeah
you
you
how many more pages of this other
wait a minute this is this stuff we
haven't covered yet oh shoot
okay this is not well organized
I won't be able to continue this as long
as I did the previous one all right
notebook interface non default options
only in the options browser so there is
a way to do that now it's not the finest
method and you know we can talk about
doing something more but I I added a
remark to the report just to make it
clear in case the reporter wasn't aware
that it is possible now absolutely okay
well I mean just having that sounds like
a new access you of how do you how do
you ask for that right yeah I mean this
is such a giant complex thing that one
would think that asking for all non
default options would be a doable thing
up here
that's just a book well I mean the big
thing to understand about the option
inspector is it it's really a
programmers interface and I mean for
this particular feature request that's
okay because clearly what's being asked
for is programming type stuff but you
know we shouldn't pretend that the
option inspector is anything other than
a programmers interface right okay to
not show do you want to evaluate all
initialization if it will happen anyway
why would it happen anyway because you
have the cells selected and yeah I've
you know if you select all styles in the
notebook you'll get that yes that's
right that's stupid
I agree yeah so yeah it's I I don't
disagree with that substring completion
for documentation search were well aware
of that issue that is under active
development modding loading boxes for
launch kernels that yes that's also
under active development that's part of
the unification of progress monitoring
through the front end processing of
dynamic updates from the kernel out of
the GUI thread
yeah well you know that's there are very
difficult issues here I mean we are
planning another service Colonel to deal
with code assistants is this an asking
for yet another service colonel to do
something yet different no no this is
what happens is that there are cases
where you are wanting to resolve a
dynamic and and it's it's synchronous so
it just waits until the colonel has
finished evaluation and sometimes that's
a short period of time and sometimes
it's a long period of time but if you're
asking for something synchronous then
waiting is the only thing that you can
do now you know and and that's really I
mean there are protocol issues
surrounding this there's also the fact
that that we don't have another option I
mean like at one option that one could
imagine is you know if you have a
dynamic box you could throw up a
placeholder and then come back and fill
it in later if you have one one question
one question here is if we look at what
the cloud is doing which is a whole
separate implementation stack with
completely different technology and
completely different ambient constraints
how consistent is it and you know other
things that we learn
the desktop front end was built in a
world where that's never okay what do
you mean how the cell you stop until you
can draw this out right but I mean your
point is that the the cloud goes on and
renders the other stuff in the notebook
and then leaves that cell saying sorry I
can't render this or I'm going to try
and render it later
yes right I mean it renders a
placeholder you know that looks nothing
like what the final version of the cell
no I understand I understand it but the
constraint on the desktop has always
been it is the gold standard you know of
what the notebook actually is is how it
renders on the desktop notwithstanding
that absolutely bizarre bug that I ran
into yesterday which I'm glad you've now
fixed um this this is the only time
that's ever happened to me if something
that appears one way I in the rendering
of the notebook but actually has a
different underlying structure that is
completely different yeah well that's
because you don't get to see all the
bugs I didn't even think that kind of
bug was possible fortunately it wasn't
there very long but um
okay in any case but I mean so the issue
here is I mean this is a more
complicated discussion about what would
be acceptable behavior in the modern
world for a desktop you know desktop
notebook rendering it's that true yeah
yeah we should head there and then you
know the the engineering requirements
behind it which may be considerable
depending on what's being asked for yeah
but maybe there's a way of doing this
that where we get a large part of the of
the benefit you know and and in some
bizarre situation as a gray box rendered
on the you know in the notebook for a
while and that probably 30 years ago
that would have been completely
unacceptable because people would just
been totally confused by it but today
with you know with web browsers loading
things asynchronously and so on that may
not be nilly it's such a confusion yeah
so we should look at that please please
okay standard characters pallets to
include standard emojis that is a
reasonable suggestion we don't have
support for standard emojis yet but
we're working towards it right that I
mean we have support in many parts of
the system but not yet in all of the
desktop notebook rendering or editing I
mean what about on the cloud don't we
have support for it in the cloud yeah
modulo editing - yeah there are still
out there okay non-english characters a
seraphs and code foam which is ugly you
mean the alphas and things like that
that's a font matching issue and that's
an issue of okay this is a very detailed
issue and it has to do with specifically
Windows specifically Microsoft and their
font fallback mechanism okay and you
know it doesn't you know the font
fallback fact items are extremely
operating system dependence and so did
we not define the correct full-back or
is it is it we don't have control over
the fallback I thought we gave a list of
don't we have an option which gives a
list of full-back fonts the know not
know what you're thinking of is if the
font doesn't exist but in this case the
font exists it just doesn't have all of
the glyphs so click on that ticket then
you'll see that it's about Chinese
characters
Pacific Lee was reported by a Chinese
user specifically about Chinese
characters and how they interact with
the other characters no I don't know
yeah I mean okay it was okay so is this
in fact as you say a Windows full-back
mechanism yet operating here yeah yeah
so how does one change it I mean is that
something you can set in the Opera you
know the interesting thing is is that I
mean there is some documentation about
this here and there but but you know
like the the the Asian character
fallback under windows doesn't seem to
always obey Microsoft's documentation
it's like they have some special
mechanisms for that I mean I mean you
know we can look into it but I'm not the
question may not be out without
completely re-implementing what should
be an operating system level feature
which I hate doing you know I know it
does we get messed up by that every time
but yeah changes and then nothing works
and so on all right let's keep going
Auto completion for second argument of
bounding region I'm sure that's just a
bug so we really need to look at this be
great to clean out things like that from
this list we really need to look at this
come on we surely don't need to look at
this here what a completion of the
second argument of bounding region I'm
sure that's just a bug let's you know
okay pause Auto completion tree work
relative to current directory its I you
know I mean first of all you might not
even have a kernel running what we're
talking about if you say something like
[Music]
both file browse or something Oh what is
it what is it really called um oh it
will be a great import import for
instance okay and then I type quotes and
then I get a file browser okay and what
directory did it go to there well in
this case it's related to recent
directories for file browsing of what
well well what's being suggested is that
it should be relative to directory
bracket brackets
I think oh the kernel can and and I
don't agree I I think this will cause
problems that well this is it this is a
complicated issue because the front end
which is running on the computer on
which this thing is running on which
this user assistance piece is running
might be different from the kernel from
the you know which could be on the other
side of a planet that is but not only
that the directory might not even be the
same when this code is actually executed
you know if you're talking one command
in isolation then yeah in the file
browser it will be lovely if we were
able to well this is a system file
browser isn't it it's an assistant file
browser yes yes it is so we don't get to
have a button there that says use the I
mean look what we could do here in this
thing here would be to have another
piece of the auto-completion here that
says something I don't know what the
wording would be but it's basically a
file browser relative to the current
directory and if it can resolve that
great see what I'm saying so in other
words it's basically file browse started
on directory open closed I think that's
a reasonable suggestion let's that's not
what what the users asking for well they
well they're asking for
they want to see completions as they
type they don't want to use the file
browse dialog the policeman they type
where as you
typing the file name if you type in a an
absolute path and you know like try
quote tilde slash tilde slash something
you know to show stuff in your home
directory for example there's a people
thing that would be a great Pietschmann
i don't know what that refers to
so be useful to know what the that
refers to I don't know does not support
this okay what are we talking about here
could somebody please process things I
can tell you I mean okay but then I
don't agree with you because because
obviously right if if you would import a
file name you know you want to write a
program that imports a file called food
PNG and and and and this is in a program
you know and it's called set directory
and done the right thing but then as
you're typing in foo you know it says oh
I happen to see in your current
directory that you have you know a food
25 dot PNG and this is what I'm gonna
offer and there's no food up PNG because
it's in the context of a program so what
so what typing the little file
completions which which you know give
you bad information or worse than no no
no no no no look look what's be that
example is spurious because in the
context of a program you're not going to
have the wrong thing that you're typing
is not what you are interested in like
the wrong thing the program is going to
be controlling what file you're looking
at etcetera the issue here I think is
that there's this issue between the you
know these other scientific computing
environments whatever they may be
probably were never built with a
client-server architecture as ours has
been for the last 33 years and therefore
they didn't have the issue that that you
are not maybe early running on what's it
maybe I can't write real program so
that's also possible too
but Tim the I think it's just the
session
right like it's not just session based
it's based on you know what's happening
at the very moment that you're typing
what is which state is the kernel in at
the very moment that you're typing guys
guys come on
this is what's being asked for is a
piece of user assistance technology that
has the feature like all user assistance
technology it tries to do the right
thing based on the information it has at
the time if it cannot figure out what to
do it if is deeply nested inside a
program it will either do nothing or I
don't know I don't know but the fact is
there is a point at which it can
perfectly well say you know if you press
a button that causes it to compute
directory at the moment when you press
the button this is really just a
question of messaging in the button here
that it is going to be something that
says file browse relative to directory
open close if it said that then you know
what you're getting and if you don't
like it well then don't press it right
in other words if there was a button
right there that said open the file
browser with the current directory as
your you know again that's not what's
being asked for it III understand that's
not what's being asked for but I'm
saying that will be a useful thing which
would achieve what you want to get to
here if you want Auto completion that is
based on I understand the argument for
not Auto completing a file name based on
just random characters that have to be
typed in I think that's a reasonable
argument what I'm saying is if you want
to get which I do think is useful a file
in your current directory this is a way
to do it right you have to pre think I'm
gonna go to a file in my current
directory let me use a file browser to
do it and let me use it sort of
completion rather than my auto
completion which as you say has problems
because you don't know whether it's
relative to the current directory or all
kinds of other things right but I think
what I'm suggesting is a compromise that
will actually achieve what's useful am I
making sense
okay right now I'm a little unclear on
the specifics I'm just saying you know
here would be file browser and then it's
relative to whatever right but it's some
but here you're asking to you know file
browse relative to yeah I mean these
things people are making comments about
random other programs they have you know
I'm sure we have come and you know file
completion if you use a text you know if
you use a kind of 1980s style interface
I'm quite certain we have that too quite
certain that if you go here we have some
kind of completion thing that works in a
terminal there aren't well we might have
I mean you probably type escape escape
when you get it but that's a completely
different problem being able to do it in
a terminal interface it's a completely
different and much simpler problem there
but in any case I think the right
solution here is to have you know file
browser relative to whatever this file
browser is relative to and it should
probably say and Frau browsers are
relative to directory open close which
you can specifically asked for that's
what I think we should do we can bring
it up in the next user assistance
meeting to confirm that
I this is a bug I don't want to see
these and that is a go a sense of auto
completion for that and it should be
generated unless it's just the default
and that's being used by default so so
so for the next one what I'm intending
to do instead is to is to implement and
you and I have talked about this before
programming ligature you've been
planning that for a while yeah III think
that the these ligatures are a slightly
complicated story because people you
know to have it so long as it visually
looks like bracket bracket still I guess
people will know how to type it well I
mean I mean I mean the whole point is
you type in the input form and it will
automatically show you kind of you know
the actual meaning of it the actual kind
of collapse I shouldn't say that because
of course bracket bracket still means
the same thing but but that you know
it's giving you a sign that it's not
just a regular set of brackets it's a
you know it is a double bracket by
virtue of you know showing it at a
special way no but I don't know how to
type that I really think that that's you
know people are always saying how do you
type that but what I'm saying is you
would still type the bracket bracket it
would show I know I I'm well aware I'm
well aware but if people see that
character they do not know how to type
it you see what I'm saying so what's
your point I'm not sure it's a great
thing to do I'm not I think it's a I
think it's not a slam-dunk obvious good
idea so the type this F brackets X
double brackets one close close close so
now imagine in a programming ligature
world where it would automatically
indicates and it may be better you know
like G of one inside there you know
instead of instead of instead of
part of 1x part of G of 1 or something
like that and you know then it you know
trying to figure out and especially if
you start you know wanting to you know
add more arguments or more levels to
your part or something like that you
know it gets difficult to to work your
way through the brackets but having the
know I think visual indicator this does
look nice I agree this looks nice I
think the way but but but but the
problem with typing these in though is
that a left double bracket does not
match two right brackets and two left
brackets don't match a right double
brackets and that's considered a syntax
error and so that's why I'm suggesting
about that right kerning basically
you're suggesting that it effectively
kearns the characters yes but but you
know the underline the underlying
serialization you know would still be
the two individual characters you typed
and in fact if you arrowed you know if
you use the arrow keys to arrow between
them they would split apart as you arrow
through them oh I see well that's a good
idea
I mean why are we not doing that I mean
- greater than could do the same thing
exactly and in fact I think that you
know if we did that we would probably
end up I mean we probably keep the input
Auto replacement stuff around but most
of the stuff that we do with it now
would probably instead become
programming ligatures yeah well which
means but there's a to that what would
happen is is you backspace through this
thing here and a person backspace would
peel off the greater-than and leave it
and leave a - that's right how weird
that will be it's interesting it's a
good idea all right I am going to have
to leave very soon so I'm afraid we're
not gonna get through the rest of this
um so hey by the way I see that it looks
like we're getting some support from the
folks on the live stream for the
get your idea good so I've been waitin
do this for a while it's just you know
well II wanted to do um okay quick way
to insert pods directly from the file
manager oh this is another this was
always possible it just the person who
reported it didn't realize how it could
be done
it's if you drag and drop a file into
into a document you get the contents of
the file they wanted the file name you
can option drag to get the file name and
they didn't realize that that was
possible but I mean it's that's that the
I mean I always pick at that too but
that's a that's a you know Mac OS su
yeah it's it's kind of one of those you
know operating systems standards that
are kind of obscure but they are
standard so these these lack of
auto-completion should just be bugs so
let's please treat them as that sure
lead up to the longest matching string
you know III think this is one of those
things about which reasonable people
could come to violent blows but yeah I
mean you know we could I say
so a keyboard mechanism to autocomplete
up to the longest uniquely matchable but
but that depends on the tale of this
creature right yeah you know that's a
mess because the tale of that I mean
it's when you say when you say a
keyboard mechanism I mean I really think
it needs you know you need to make a
choice you can't offer both you need to
make a choice and maybe that I may be
the choice could be an option you could
argue about that but wait wait wait
that's the right now it's the first
total completion that you got by typing
enter right ah that's right assuming
that you don't like use the arrow keys
to navigate that exactly but well you to
have another key like tab for example
that auto-completed up to the longest
you know like having an entrance tab do
different things would be incredibly
confusing
well those tab do everything right now
it autocompletes so it does I mean you
know it's my perception that lots of
people use tab and lots of people use
enter I actually tend to use tab but I
think a lot of people out there use
Center and and having them do different
things I think that's a huge mistake
right I mean if you really wanted to get
cutesy with it you could have shift-tab
do this but nobody would ever know that
I think that's better than having some
weird global setting to you know say do
you want to do I mean but this idea I
think it's a mistake to you know there's
already enough pressure on the
autocomplete secret you know menu it's
like well should we add that thing in
the tail well if we add that in the tail
it's gonna kill the whole animal so to
speak well you know I mean I mean in my
view you just you know I've seen systems
that do one way I've seen systems that
do the other I mean like filename
completion from the shell you know from
bash you know I know that does exactly
what's being described here
yes but filenames are a different story
I'm entering the the problem here is
that there can be something way in the
tail where it's kind of nice
to have that in the autocomplete menu
but were you to add it it's very
sensitive to that
you know addition because it's going to
affect you know you know longest
substring you know completion right I
think this is I agree this is a mistake
you know the only thing I could imagine
is some cutesy key combination to do it
proper syntax coloring with with I think
that's just a implementation thing that
is slowly going to get done should show
pop-up should show documentation link
for package functions yes I'm sure
that's correct I mean that's probably
just a missing piece um I don't know
what that is there I mean that's crazy
that thing down there is just nuts and
shouldn't be there I mean I think
there's an argument that you know except
for some very special cases one should
not I mean arguably unless one's
explicitly loaded a package
one should not autocomplete to package
to context names not other words unless
the session has had that context name
either explicitly loaded or typed
somehow it shouldn't be mentioned in the
autocomplete list well that stuff is
really noise I'm not sure what's
intended by the screen shot given the
the matech being loaded there I mean
that's a pointed to some reason that the
symbols in that didn't show up here no
no click on it click on the second image
that's the better notice that's fine who
doesn't information thing now click on
the second one and I noticed that
magnetic does not have the information
thing even though there is a documented
page from a tech function that's so
where is that documentation page so this
must be it yeah so it's there in
principle it's findable if you press
I've lon
if you go to the document well and and
and and the more general story is that
we don't have as much functionality and
what we do have isn't as documented as
well as it should be for people who are
writing back was to plug into the you
know various user assistance stuff right
and that's something I totally concede
that that's right but I mean if there is
a standard place where the documentation
plug-in happens from that packet we
should be able to find that that should
be a fairly straightforward piece of
low-hanging fruit yeah click on the
third image link you'll see you'll see
that the difference like go back one and
now click on the third one if you see it
has it there the eye is there and so you
know like on the right of that image you
can see I understand I understand I
understand I got it right the point is
that when the packet was loaded they're
hooking in that it did to hook this
thing into the documentation system did
not hook it into the user assistance
system that's the issue right yeah and
that is a good idea and it should be
done okay unfortunately I have to go and
so much as I would love to continue this
I think this will have to continue after
the holidays um and we did finish that
section didn't we yes I just want to say
that somebody suggests something in the
live stream that looks a lot like the
fuzzy auto-completion matching which we
are working on I don't know if it's
going to be in twelve one or not but we
are very actively working on it so
there's a demo belen they and the
prototype build I'm not sure if it's on
my defaults no no it's not on my fault
so yeah we're still working on it to
make it not stupid so to speak
okay all right well so next time we will
start I think we might do even better
than to put these in alphabetical order
but we're going to have a bunch of sound
symbolics system okay those are the
esses well they looked like some
interesting suggestions here all right I
much as I would like to go on right now
let's not do that and let's pick this up
probably in the first week of the new
year and unless people wanted I I think
I think we won't have enough people
around next week um okay thanks all very
much and see you soon bye